[Music]
welcome to fandom incorporated's bureau
for abnormal psychology research and
response
hi today's patient loki odinson
god of mischief with the assistance of
dr
drea letta mendy sector chief of
superhuman behavioral therapy
the following case conceptualization and
treatment plan has been prepared
session one past traumas loki's past
traumas include condemned to life in a
prison by his own father
resurrected a demon to kill a sister
discovered his real father was the king
of his foreign enemy
multiple betrayals at the hands of
allies and enemies multiple physical
assaults
and multiple deaths both real and staged
[Music]
assessment self-destructive behavior to
avoid the recurring traumas
of being hurt betrayed and rejected by
others looking will preemptively create
his own chaos
wherever you go it's just death
destruction the literal ends of worlds
by sabotaging relationships and
backstabbing his allies loki avoids the
pain
he's come to expect in the future ergo
loki's past traumas have led him to
believe it is always
always better to be the first one to
strike
session two relationships love love-hate
relationship
with adoptive mother frigga now deceased
distant relationship with adoptive
father odin
now deceased loki murdered his
biological father
biological mother unknown love hate
relationship with adopted brother thor
close friends zero assessment
persistence of love hate relationships
suggests potential borderline
personality disorder
people with bpd idolize the qualities
and abilities of those close to them
but to cope with their feelings they
violate the boundaries of those
relationships
i trust you you betray me round and
round in circles we come
it's an all or nothing style of relating
alternating between
idealization and devaluation so in other
words to cope with his fears of
rejection
loki often splits his brother hating him
or loving him
and with his mother frigga idolizing her
or vilifying her
based on the circumstances and the
moment rather than a consistency in the
relationship
in which they are human or asgardian in
this case and flawed
session three sense of self
loki's self perception appears to be
warped by the following delusions of
grandeur savior
is here toxic shame extreme insecurity
machiavellianism narcissism you are all
of you beneath me
i am a god you dull creature and
psychopathy
he was totally ready to kill any of us
he did try to kill me yes
me too many occasions assessment the
presence of machiavellianism
narcissism psychopathy form what's known
as the dark triad of personality
disorders
the presence of all three indicates a
propensity to commit crimes
cause social distress and frankly create
severe problems for an organization
i've care how you speak he's my brother
he killed 80 people in two days
he's adopted however as opposed to
previous subjects such as thanos or
malaketh
loki's dark triad traits are partially
offset by a sense of humor
you've literally stabbed people on the
back like 50 times
why never do it again as well as high
levels of perceptiveness
and the potential for close
relationships it is with this in mind
that in this case we recommend
treatment over termination when working
with individuals with early experience
of abandonment rejection or ruptures we
recommend traveling back to the moment
or
age when they first started to have
significant or chronic thoughts of
inadequacy
perhaps the tva or stark industries
could assist
perhaps a time machine loki must return
to when he first thought to himself
i'm different or i'm not good enough so
i am no more than another stolen relic
then investigate what he did and now
does to compensate for those feelings
for example dressing flamboyantly or
trying to conquer the earth
loki also has an opportunity to improve
his low self-esteem by experiencing
belongingness
not through ascending to the monarchy
perhaps but through the shared
resilience of his adoptive people the
asgardians
by contributing to the formation of the
new asgard community
loki can reconcile and rebuild his
damaged self
though only a less developed loki
remains alive in the current timeline
alternate histories prove that loki has
the opportunity for growth
standing up to thanos proves he's
capable of choosing good over evil
and that this would bring him some small
measure of peace
i loki odin son
in that timeline loki located some much
needed if not overdue
compassion for himself and the
recognition that at the end of his life
lacking ownership of titles and people
he is still truly worthy
though should be noted not of the hammer
that is just not for him
analysis complete next patient
[Music]
boy
you